- [Instructor] As we talked
about in other videos,
shortly after the
Declaration of Independence
in July of 1776, the representatives from
what were colonies but
now self-declared states
had to think about how
to organize themselves.
And so they start drafting
the Articles of Confederation,
which go into effect in 1781.
Now as we'll see,
Articles of Confederation
do not provide for any type
of real central government.
It really was a mutual defense union
with a little bit of free trade,
as well see in the text here.
This is some of the beginning passages
of the Articles of Confederation,
and I encourage you to
read the whole thing,
it's actually quite interesting.
But you immediately see it
has a very different tone
than the one that we see
in the US Constitution.
The Constitution starts
with "we the people,"
while the Articles of
Confederation starts with
"to all to whom these
Presents shall come,"
so it's almost, you know,
kind of an awkward business letter.
"We the undersigned
Delegates of the States
"affixed to our Names send greeting.
"Articles of Confederation
and perpetual Union
"between the states of New
Hampshire, Massachusetts-bay,
"Rhode Island and Providence Plantations,
"Connecticut, New York,
New Jersey, Pennsylvania,
"Delaware, Maryland,
Virginia, North Carolina,
"South Carolina and Georgia.
"The Stile of this Confederacy shall be
"'The United States of America.'"
This part is interesting.
"Each state retains its sovereignty,"
so it rules over itself,
it's not giving up its sovereignty
to some type of a union.
So it "retains its
sovereignty, its freedom,
"and independence, and every
power, jurisdiction, and right,
"which is not by this Confederation
"expressly delegated to the United States,
"in Congress assembled."
So they're really viewing themselves
as independent countries
that are next to each other
that for the sake of fighting
the Revolutionary War,
agree to things like mutual
defense and free trade,
but they are really separate countries.
"The said States hereby severally
enter into a firm league
"of friendship with each other,
for their common defense,"
so this is that mutual defense idea,
"the security of their liberties,
"and their mutual and general welfare,
"binding themselves to assist each other
"against all force offered
to, or attacks made upon them,
"or any of them, on account of
religion, sovereignty, trade,
"or any other pretense whatever."
And then it says, "the better
to secure and perpetuate
"mutual friendship and
intercourse among the people
"of the different States in this Union,
"the free inhabitants of
each of these States...
"shall be entitled to all
privileges and immunities
"of free citizens in the several States;
"and the people of each State
shall free ingress and regess
"to and from any other State,
and shall enjoy therein
"all the privileges of
trade and commerce."
So people could travel back
and forth between these states,
there would be free trade,
but these would be viewed
as different countries.
One interesting thing that you don't hear
people talk a lot about, there
is even a little passage here
that allows Canada to
join this confederation.
"Canada, acceding to this confederation,
"and adjoining in the
measures of the United States,
"shall be admitted into, and
entitled to all the advanatages
"of this Union; but no other
colony shall be admitted
"into the same, unless such admission
"be agreed to by nine States."
So they're saying hey, if Canada agrees,
they are pre-agreeing to allow
Canada to join this union,
which Canada obviously does not join.
But it's interesting to think
that they thought about this.
Now what are the weaknesses here?
Well the most obvious one,
I don't have the entire
Articles of Confederation here,
but how does this United States
of America wield its power?
Where does its money come from?
It turns out that if it
needs to generate revenue
in order to take some action,
it can't tax the citizens of the states,
the states can only do that themselves.
Instead it has to apply to the states
in order to contribute to
the United States of America.
If you want to take some
type of unified action,
well you would have to have delegates
from the various states, and meet together
and decide what to do.
You wouldn't have any strong leader
being able to take decisive action.
And so there really wasn't a notion
of a central government here.
There wasn't even a notion
of one country, one nation.
It really was about
different sovereign states.
And all of this, as we'll
see, will come to a head
in the mid-1780s.
The United States has a
significant amount of debt
exiting the American Revolutionary War.
Debt to countries like France.
You also have debt on
the individual level.
Merchants owe money to
European merchants and traders
and lenders, and these
lenders weren't interested
in paper currency from
these newly created states.
They wanted hard
currency, they wanted gold
and they want silver.
And so many of the merchants
in the United States
in turn put pressure on the
people they lend money to,
especially poor farmers, many
of whom had been veterans
in the Revolutionary War,
to pay their debts in hard currency.
And so you can imagine these poor farmers
who were kind of the
bottom of this food chain
were in a pretty tough bind.
They had fought in the Revolutionary War,
they had risked their lives,
many of them had been injured,
but they actually did not
get paid for their service,
to a large degree.
And then now, they were not
able to even survive as farmers,
because not only were they
not able to borrow new funds,
but some of their existing funds
they had to pay back in hard currency,
which wasn't available
in the United States.
And so all of this tension
eventually comes to a head
in western Massachusetts.
This right here is a
picture of Daniel Shays,
who was one of these poor
farmers in western Massachusetts
who was also a veteran of the
American Revolutionary War
who was not paid for his service.
And so he eventually
becomes one of the leaders
of these rebellious former
veterans, poor farmers,
and they start taking the courthouses
of western Massachusetts,
making them inoperable.
These were the courthouses
where people had to report to
in order to talk about how
they would repay their debt.
Well you can imagine this
worried many of the merchants
who these people owed their debt to.
It also worried many of
the founding fathers,
because it took some time
for the government of Massachusetts
to be able to react to this,
and while that was happening,
through mid-1786 into
the beginning of 1787,
this rebellion got stronger
and stronger and stronger.
Eventually, on January 25th, 1787,
we see things coming to a head
where Daniel Shays is leading his rebels
to take the armory in
Springfield, Massachusetts,
which is in western Massachusetts,
but stopped by militia.
This is a militia that's paid
for by merchants in the area,
who probably want their debt paid,
or just wanted functioning courthouses,
or did not want all of
these rioting farmers
and former veterans.
And so this rebellion is put down,
but it shows the weakness inherent
in the Articles of Confederation.
This rebellion starts having
the potential to spread
well beyond Massachusetts.
But there was not a coordinated action.
In fact, it took many
months to even be able
to field a militia against the rebellion.
It also highlighted the weakness
of not having one central government
that could take decisive action.
Also one central government
that could generate its own revenue
through taxing the citizens
of all of the states
and using that for things like a military,
or being able to negotiate
debts with foreign countries.
And so Shays' Rebellion is
cited by many historians
as one of the main catalysts,
after it was put down,
for having the Constitutional
Convention in mid-1787
to rethink the Articles of Confederation.
Now as we talked about in other videos,
many people went to
this convention thinking
we're not just gonna edit the
Articles of Confederation,
we need to create a
stronger central government.
We need a federalist system where yes,
the states can have rights,
but we also need a central government.
We need a strong leader
at the head of that central government.
And so they do draft what
is now the Constitution
at this convention, and
after the convention,
they sell this new constitution,
because remember, it has to
be ratified by the states
through the Federalist Papers,
which we also talk about in other videos,
Hamilton organized it,
but James Madison and John Jay
also significant contributors,
and eventually, the
Articles of Confederation
does get replaced, the
Constitution is ratified,
and it becomes effective
on March 4th, 1789.